let's let's start to unfold this now I
left one step off before I could
actually use this because as you can see
like I've got my detainer of D Thea
that's good but I don't actually have a
1 plus T squared on to in my integrand
right as there's no way they're so i'm
going to rewrite this slightly so i can
put it into something that i can service
you do so i'm going to divide both sides
by 1 plus z squared i'll do okay is that
all right so that way I'll have one on
the right hand side like so and the one
I've been substituting where I like
those dvds will cancel okay let's have
an obvious this is equal to the what
does the integrated big hug before I
change the variable education what does
it become this is cause so actually what
the reciprocal of this yes so this is
going to be 1 minus t squared so I have
the other one pastis can one learn to
describe be happy with that x this guy
rhymes
cancel cancel yeah looking good so far
so you can see here cool these guys are
going to go which leaves you with two on
I'm going to factorize it why am I going
to factorize because i'm going to use
partial fractions here ok now we
actually did this same set of partial
fractions before do you recall remember
I had to do some because I didn't want
to go to tea results yet because I
wanted to go there this morning I had to
do some sort of treat tomfoolery up here
before I got to this line but you
already had the partial fractions right
what's it equal to what's what's the
pair of fractions you'll get one on and
one on right oh you've already done this
right you've got your AUB is that look
good there was a half last time but we
have a few cancers you see yeah that's
right you see I changed right so add
that to their wasn't there before I had
a one-on-one months I think I just you
or something like that so is this look
good so far all right so I get out of
that these are my long terms right I'll
be careful cuz you've got reverse chain
rule here so this is in fact minus log
of 1 minus T plus I showed up today so
fast log off 1 plus T yeah that look
good and then i'm going to rewrite it as
a single log term if this will take
about this wonderful yes I'm gonna write
as a division
yeah so far so good okay now at this
point I'm going to keep it on the left
hand boy I am almost there right I
introduce tea in order to make the
integration like handle the ball but now
that I have done the integration I'm
going to get rid of him now ok so
there's what t is so I'm going to say
this is equal to lure not absolute value
and I'm just going to do the
substitution she's Taylor fever ok what
do you think how's it look does it look
correct do you get it did you get ok now
this this is interesting to me it's very
interesting to me because this is kind
of not what I was expecting because like
I said we did this question before what
do we get last time when we do what do
we go this morning sir no is what do we
get when we integrated Cynthia log off
did we get a lot now that was when we
went from the the one on the square root
of x squared plus it's bad but Kia we're
just dealing with this guy yeah now hold
on a minute plus constant hold on hold
on hold on those looks super different
to me do they not super super different
I mean there's there are logs that's
kind of that's kind of good but that
you've got these look drastically
different ok now i will tell you right
off the bat that thumbs up you got it
you know them nothing wrong with it as
far as i can tell and there's I've done
some working room ok but you guys are
right there too now when I first started
learning about our like an extension one
when you first meet your first trig
identities right like and when I say
triggers I don't being the perfect Orion
ones or like the compliment ones would
just come out the definitions I mean
stuff like sub garbled mess with
fractions and two thieves and three
theatres and then some other thing and
it's like hey can you go to prove these
and I always wondered where do these
come from like who who cooked these up
and why like ok these two things are
equal I'm just going to show the recoil
and let me
do that for fun that is not where
trigonal is as an idea came from they
came from things like this so we have
approached this same problem in two
different ways and we've come up with
two or what looks like completely
different answers they are not
completely different license you go
through check these should be the same
so how do we find out because I was
virtually used to mark before at this
point you have a choice you're either
right or you're wrong yeah with this
rather right or wrong so the question is
if you're wrong what how did you what
mistakes did you make but if you are
right how is it that these things look
so different yeah yep put on pause let
me let me write that do you say y plus
yep so I'm going to go off this is going
to become 1 plus 10 feet onto squared
yeah and this is going to become one yes
oops I'm gay sex and pop said 1-2 10
feet onto mine is sorry one partner too
yep pause ten square yep one then you
just like the woman yep 50 my favorite
piece appeared okay yeah that's fine
separated yep so you're going to break
this apart into two yes the one plus tan
square beyond food over 1 minus hands my
feet or two and you come another
fraction which is too yeah hold on I'm
gonna catch up with you yeah so you've
got one there which is on 1-10 square
yeah I'm sorry yep we've got that one
plus two team over 1 minus left hands
like the inner tube and then you've got
one plus can detour through my foot
that's the SEC and the second one is
Kaos okay huh stop yeah so you see where
do you see where she's going so this is
1 plus T squared on 1 minus t squared
which is the reciprocal of this that's
log of Seck theta is it not and then
what's this guy that's already that's
already in this fall you see so it
didn't even require that much leg wait
to see indeed these two are the same
you're not momentarily freaks Yancy oh
no what have I done but you've gone okay
there's no reason why you have to do
that by the way like getting to the
slice big thumbs up because you've done
what you set out to do you climb down to
the T results you climb back out and
it's exactly right as you can see I was
we just proven okay